In a market, humans with unlimited wants
often meet sellers with limited supplies.
In such a place, competition is usually
a force of good. It leads to more choice,
increases the quality of products on offer and
reduces their prices. If competition is absent,
monopolies can form. And that's a problem.
Adam Smith, the father of modern economics,
defined competition as “allocating productive
resources to their most highly valued uses.”
For sellers, the money they receive when
they sell is more productive than their
product. For buyers, the produce they
get is more productive than their money.
When a deal is done, neither party may
be entirely happy with the agreed price,
but at the end both feel better off.
In a competitive market, those who want
something the most, end up getting it.
Competition takes various forms,
as the following story illustrates.
One dealer in a market decides to bring
in bananas to be the first to sell them.
He is the only one and since people love
bananas, he sells them at a high price.
And it doesn’t take long for someone else
to see an opportunity for improvement.
Competing on price is the most straightforward
way in which sellers can compete for customers,
because consumers usually prefer to pay less.
In order to survive, the first
seller, also known as “incumbent”,
may also lower the prices. This pressure on
prices is usually leaving customers better off.
In theory, this back and forth will continue until
both have reached a price that yields zero profit.
Then one may decide to close.
But there is also Non-price competition.
Instead of offering a lower price, newcomers can
try to sell higher quality products or innovate.
In response to innovators, incumbents may try to
improve their offers and come up with
ideas to strengthen their position.
Both may increase their service hours.
So besides lowering prices, another
consequence of competition is the range
of choices and innovation; both of which
are good for the people in the market.
In a free market, competition defines the
ultimate price and quality of goods on offer,
a phenomenon referred to as emergent order.
That means, it’s eventually not up to the shop
to decide how much to charge for a product,
but intangible forces such as supply, demand
and consumer preferences that emerge over time.
If one company is the only one selling
a product, we speak of a monopoly.
Then the benefits of competition fade, and
the naturally emergent order gets disrupted.
From perfect competition to
monopoly lies a spectrum we
can use to define the intensity of competition
In a highly transparent market we
have almost perfect competition
with low prices and lots of consumer choice.
In a market that is dominated by
a monopoly, prices are often high,
and the variety of options decreases.
If just a few companies share the market,
we speak of Oligopoly, which is also a
problem as they often secretly fix prices.
In a free and open market with high competition,
we see innovative suppliers, happy customers
and an immersive variety of choice.
On the other end of the
spectrum, we have a monopoly.
Suppliers have little bargaining power,
the goods they sell are often inferior,
customers pay higher prices and wait longer hours.
In order for markets to function, governments need
to break monopolies up and consumers
should support those that rival them.
Only then will we see innovation, good products,
low prices, happy customers and
markets that leave everyone better off.
In summary: Competition usually leads to lower
prices, innovation and higher living standards
Monopolies usually lead to higher prices,
inferior products and lower living standards
We should try to break up monopolies
to support free market competition.
To learn more about competition,
tell us how you would compete!
First find a product or service available
online or in your neighborhood with very
little competition. Describe the
service and tell us why you think
there is little competition. Is it because of
a monopoly? Or because the demand is so low,
that there is little profit to be
made? Or is there another reason?
Now assume you are opening
a competing business. Tell
us 3 things that you would do in order to compete.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com